ah la salle grillée tu fais une très
mauvaise émission pourquoi la seule
grille la seule grillée la seule grillée
[ __ ] elle par contre ça coûte
la sole grillé déjà la salle grillée
généralement tu la vois au moins 30
balles
on dirait que la sole frère quand il
t'amène la sole mon frère tu as envie de
lui parler à la sonnette
je te dis frère la seule je lui dire
pourquoi tu es aussi cher mon frère
la seule non attends la seule c'est très
cher une seule 30 vapeur tu prends moi
j'ai dit avec une meuf au restaurant
j'écoute-moi bien on s'arrête tout de
suite
mais c'est quoi mais ça va être ça tous
les soirs tous les soirs et les trucs
bébé je te jure président
[Applaudissements]
donc toi tu as pris le seul à minuit en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on fait absolument
avec quoi des petits légumes non j'avoue
que j'ai fait une petite impasse papa
notre président d'accord alors lui son
plat préféré c'est la seule ça veut dire
que lui c'est je vous dis la seule tu en
mange une fois par an quoi
baisser ton salaire
ma chérie
tout ce qui est à base de riz de toute
façon j'adore le tu es pas sorti
[Rires]
les pâtes à la bolognaise j'adore ah
ouais c'est vrai
attention
très bien sérieux
parce que vous voulez n'importe quoi
vraiment dans les poissons tu fais tu
sais même pas les quantités tu vois rien
c'est un excellent cuisinier tu es
surtout un excellent mytho cet été
excellent cuisinier tu serais pas marié
cinq fois
ça n'a rien à voir alors là
c'est quoi toi
[Musique]
en fait
les buffets ça me fait chier pourquoi
franchement tu es comme un con avec ton
assiette là tout le monde parle en plus
il crache comme ça tu es sur les trucs
pour avoir pas tout ça et donc les plats
parce que les mecs passent comme ça donc
forcément il te parle il parle et donc
il crache sur les trucs comme ça et
quand tu arrives en dernier je veux te
dire que c'est plus de la sauce c'est
plus de l'huile que tu as dedans c'est
du crachat
[Musique]
[Rires]
ce que je fais moi quand je mange avec
des gars ou je sais qu'ils positionne
beaucoup déjà des jeunes jamais que
personne c'est vrai en plus et je mets
des bouteilles devant pour certains
veulent me parler donc on dit j'ai
écoute moi je vous parlerai après
on a rien à dire bonjour
exactement il a eh il a craqué
c'était Carglass j'ai eu un impact une
pièce de 2 euros
vous êtes tellement drôle et vous
divertir tellement toute la famille que
j'ai explosé derrière j'ai craché
il a craché dans mon truc je me kiffe en
plus il m'a flingué la journée je suis
désolé non mais donc il a quitté
l'aventure il a quitté la table
le poulet yassa
non mais sans déconner c'est
insupportable non mais sérieux et je
parle à Fatou et je vais dire un truc
je vous le dis un mec qui en fait trop
comme ça c'est qu'il a quelque chose à
se reprocher je vous dis la vérité un
mec qui en fait trop sur sa meuf comme
ça moi j'ai une technique
et vous avez un truc qui va vous faire
pardonner n'envoyez pas un bouquet de
fleurs de ouf un petit bouquet sinon on
va dire le bouquet de fleurs d'eau c'est
qu'il a un truc à se faire reprocher
et toi toi t'en fais tes tests
franchement mais toi tu dois être mais
toi tu veux que je te dise mais toi tu
me dégoûtes
mais je sais mais l'amener tout le monde
aujourd'hui
non non je te le dis quand on fait trop
avec ta meuf pour être honnête je te le
dis mais elle cuisine divinement
et je veux dire j'ai attention j'étais à
l’œil
des conneries derrière quand il est tout
nu c'est quoi la connerie un petit
toutou parce que il a peur de se faire
cramer Mathieu vrais ou pas il en fait
trop rire
[Applaudissements]
je suis d'accord je vois pas qui
voudrait vraiment sortir avec Gilles
verder
tu es méchant
non non non je te vois avec un mec c'est
ça que tu me passes et tu veux que je
suis américain
ouais je pense que tu peux après Fatou
après Fatou si dans la déception
je vous l'ai déjà dit
qu'est-ce qu'elle mange cette idée du
Moyen-Âge
alors c'est du mammouth grillé
ce soir
tout simple mais d'un bon poulet rôti
avec du jus avec la peau croustillante
parce que j'ai pas de four chez moi
[Musique]
oh oui
[Rires]
le croustille
[Applaudissements]
sur la même longueur d'onde
les belles cuisent bien
le poulet bien rôti
je vais te montrer mon poulet rôti
[Rires]
je pourrais pas manger comme ça
à table le poulet que tu ramènes comme
ça
castérix et Obélix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi elle a porté des menhirs
celle-là
[Rires]
t'as pas de four alors qu'est-ce que
j'en ai à [ __ ]
le travail
une autre émission sur ces sa cuisine si
vous voulez machine à laver mais j'en ai
rien à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon voilà merci alors moi j'adore
les penins
[Applaudissements]
ça fait transpirer dans l'eau ça fait 30
spirituel
[Rires]
même la chanson termine au bois de
Boulogne
pendant des heures et des heures avec
des pommes de terre des carottes des
poireaux des céleri
avec du paleron j'ai deux noix et la
viande en fait elle est tellement cuite
elle est petite
[Rires]
avec des pommes de terre
avec plaisir
[Applaudissements]
franchement le tabac oui c'est pas une
tarte aux dents
frère tu crois quoi
avec des zombies
peut-être franchement non lâche
ses frères
ah ouais quand je mange chez ma mère il
donne des extincteurs après
[Applaudissements]